hey wordsmiths let me introduce you to a
spectacular new word it's oh
oh dear there's been an incident uh this
Manatee has taken several bites out of
the word spectacular
well fine uh we are nothing if not
flexible here at Khan Academy so let us
instead pivot to the word incident
itself
it's a noun
it means an unforeseen and usually bad
thing that happens like a manatee taken
several bites out of my vocabulary word
thanks pal sorry to be the bearer of bad
news but hey at least I can be the
bearer of good word origins huh come on
incident comes from the Latin in C today
which means to fall upon or to happen
and we can break that into two parts in
which means in or on and sidere which
means to fall so an incident is an event
that fell upon you or happened now
normally this is the part of the video
where I ask you to come up with some
similar sounding words and we will get
to that but I wanted to head off some
confusion cedara is different from side
which means to kill and shows up in
words like homicide or pesticide right
to killing a person or killing pests
killing a bug different words so
um when we look for words that share a
root with incident they'll typically be
pronounced Sid instead of side anyway
let's do the thing you've got 10 sec
begins to come up with words that use
the prefix in or the root Sid I'll put
on some music
[Music]
here are some words I came up with
sedent a chance happening in unexpected
mistake coincidence right which is when
two or more things happen at once
without having been planned
co-incident things happening together
and inspect which is to look at
something carefully looking
in
let's use incident in a sentence because
I think that'll get across its bad news
connotation
sadly
the incident in the library destroyed
all the books it was a bummer to lose
all those books an unfortunate thing
happened incident can also sometimes be
a euphemism a way of saying something
ugly happened without having to name it
note that I'm saying the incident and
not the Fire or the horrific cotton
candy machine malfunction this would as
it happens also be really bad for all
the books ah uh okay wordsmiths I have
to go there's been an incident
I think the manatees back
and it's still hungry uh I'll catch you
all next time huh you can learn anything
David out